property has been an obsession for
Chinese and part of the reason is that
if you look at the financial system what
can you invest in uh if you have some
money uh stack it under your mattress as
one putting in the uh in Banks and
earning a zero real rate of return is
another or uh putting into the roller
coaster stock market which haven't
really paid off so there are not a lot
of choices so even as an investment
property has been uh very popular for
Chinese households now in places like
Shanghai the demand is so high that
you'll have these kind of very creative
ways and by the way not surprising at
all uh to deal with and to circumvent
these restrictions and we have to
understand there are the restrictions
being what being that you're not
eligible to purchase a second house
unless you meet certain certain
Criterion so divorce was one of uh the
possibilities um but there also all all
kinds of rules that I can't keep track
of but we have to understand there's a
big heterogene it throughout with within
China the first and second tier cities
which do show the first tier cities show
evidence of a of a property bubble
whereas for the rest of the country
there is no evidence of property bubble
because the growth of property prices
has been roughly in line with household
income growth uh and so for many third
fourth tier cities the price can still
keep on going up yeah but but in in
Shanghai Beijing Etc they the prices are
at least by Western s it's kind of out
of whack with income well no we have to
think about it this way housing price is
an expectations of the future if you
believe Beijing and Shanghai is going to
be a Cosmopolitan Global City of the
likes of New York and Tokyo then high
prices show up today so it could also
reflect highly optimistic views about
the future and now you can say that is
no longer rationalized so there will be
an adjustment but for a long period of
time they were looking forward and by
the way there are a lot of really
wealthy Chinese people around so yeah I
mean is again you talked about how the
younger generation have certain
parallels with the issues that young
people in the west have and you must
have a view on both because you teach at
the lsse so you know lots of kind of you
know uh Western students but you also
you know have teach in Beijing and so on
um is there the same sense amongst the
Chinese young that the system isn't
working for them anymore or rather that
if you're a member of the elite if
you've already got money or if you've
got connection you'll be okay but if
you're not you're kind of looking
looking uh from the outside in I mean I
remember when I was in Beijing at one
point talking to a a student at shinua
he was a he made it you know but he was
from a small City and he said you know
there's so many kids in my class from a
few schools in Beijing uh you know from
my city maybe one person got to this
University and it reminded me of the
kind of laments you get here in Britain
about oh well you know the sort of the
rich still dominate universities all
Harvard Legacy students do you see a
parallel that meritocracy has always
been the Bedrock of society Chinese
Society especially in the last 40 years
there's an argument to be made that
there's somewhat of an erosion of
meritocracy meritocracy which I find to
be uh very frustrating and high a big
challenge uh to China uh but still until
very recently if you look at the surveys
the expectations of the young is still
pretty Rosy uh in China uh big contrast
to the uh younger generation around the
world it was only during the pandemic
where many of the University students
felt extremely frustrated I think that
some of that sentiment has changed um
but uh there there is not the sense that
the system isn't working for them it's
the you know whether the economy can
recover enough that there will be
confidence that there will be jobs and
yes there's a greater frustration with
the circumstances but these young people
look at what's happening outside of
China they look and they are not
inspired they look at what what's
happening with democracies with what's
happening with the random police
shootings in the US uh or uh the
democracies that have been transposed
onto foreign soil uh in various parts of
the world uh they look at the chaos uh
in Hong Kong they're not inspired they
don't think that there's an alternative
of a better model and that shows in the
surveys in surveys they ask the younger
generation whether China will be suited
for a different an alternative model and
the majority of them do not believe so
even though they admit that they're huge
challenges for the Chinese I was
actually kind of um had an question
about those figures you site because you
say that you know 38% of young Chinese
say that a western political model would
not be suitable for China but that
leaves open the possibility that the
other sort of two-thirds might think it
was suitable the the sentiment towards
the West um changed in 2017 so I'd say
that before 2017 many of them were quite
attracted by um uh different forms of
political systems at least as a
possibility for China and looking at the
west but but things did take a dramatic
change uh move in 2017 what happened
then
Trump as a as an example and of course
with Rising tensions of us China now but
of course 2017 is also the year that she
amends the Constitution and allow
extends his period in power so that
could also cause a few question marks
yeah but that's the that's the the time
when um the the Western Perceptions in
particular have uh turned shifted for
the negative we just have to understand
that there superficial globalization you
know the fact that we like Hollywood and
NBA etc etc
thaton ex very appealing for for the
young Chinese but their cultural roots
are overwhelmingly local as I show in my
book the statistics 80% of the students
from 2013 have returned to China not
only because it's close to home because
they have good Chinese food of course
that's important but also because of the
opportunities that are afforded them the
entrepreneurial Spirit the fact that
people had great jobs in Google and
Facebook also opt to go back to China to
make their life uh and the fact that
they're creating their H grown kind of
culture modern culture Cosmic poan
culture so vibrant in the second tier
cities so they they they are fostering a
different environment there yeah I mean
how has the pandemic and the handling of
the pandemic affected the relationship
between people and the government
because you mentioned it ended very
suddenly when there were young people
demonstrating and that was quite
striking that the government shifted so
quickly um what what do you make of that
episode more than an episode a couple of
years I was reassured that when there
was concerted pressure from the younger
generation but also from uh the people
potentially even the local governments
um that uh such a you know such a such a
a long-term kind of or or steadfast
policy was broken it shows that there
are mechanism this is a very important
point that there are mechanism embedded
in the systems uh whether it's from the
people and social media or the
competitive mechanism within the Chinese
government that makes it so that
preferences are still revealed and
potentially shape the outcomes of
political and economic decisions now of
course that is the ongoing challenge as
the Chinese government has to manage a
much more complex society going forward
not like the time when I was born and
everybody was content with having a
growing income today it's increasingly
complex but this new generation Young
Generation overturning a key policy was
more positive for me but we also forget
but but you say the preferences revealed
I mean they were revealed by people
demonstrating on the streets it wasn't a
particularly sophisticated polling
exercise absolutely but it's a two-way
monitoring system and social media
creates that kind of platform uh not
only for the Chinese government to uh to
watch what was happening on the ground
but other way as well and I think that
um basically
um the the the complex well anyway let
me start over um I think the complexity
of the society is a big challenge for
the Chinese government and they do
listen they do listen now I still think
the ongoing challenge is how do you have
the political mechanism to include the
much more important participants of the
economy like the private businessman ENT
entrepreneur in that system if they
don't do it and they don't adapt the
system is not going to be as powerful or
will uh enable the Chinese dreams as
irations that it has laid out yeah and
he used the phrase the Chinese Dream
It's one that shishan ping uses and he
talks about the great Rejuvenation of
the Chinese people but I know some
economists worry that she is so statist
uh as they see it that he's in danger of
killing that entrepreneurial spirit and
they Point particularly to the fate of
Jack Mah who was the the icon of of
Chinese business appeared to say
something or do something the government
didn't like and is now as far as we know
sort of teaching students in Tokyo
um he's called back now oh really is he
well yeah well well tell me first what
you made of that episode but also more
broadly what it said about the
government's relationship with the most
dynamic business elements in society
well the first thing to note is broadly
speaking there can be a coexistence of
seemingly paradoxical and
irreconcilable uh things in China that's
something that perhaps a western
audience ought to keep in mind and that
no policy is permanent they're
constantly being fine Ted so the pretext
of this is uh Under the Umbrella of
common Prosperity under President XI how
to achieve Equitable growth but I think
um more may perhaps what the audience
can relate to is that uh in she's view
China doesn't want to be uh like the US
highly uh a high growth a great economy
but highly inequitable and uh politics
sing to the tunes of corporates China
wants an olive shaped income
distribution narrow on the ends and fat
in the middle it wants the corporates to
sing to the politics to sing to the
tunes of politics and so um this initial
dramatic sweeping Regulatory clampdowns
and technology companies that had
consequences for personalities and
private uh businessmen uh uh such as uh
Jack ma uh was of course a devasting
blow to the economy because of the
confidence issue um however you wipe a
trillion dollars off the stock exchange
it did because extraord because American
investors didn't couldn't make what was
was going to happen to the private
entrepreneurs and that's all very
understandable now that's a painful
lesson for the Chinese government
understanding that whatever they say
their intentions their Ambitions have
real economic and immediate Capital
markets consequences that was not the
case in the old Playbook which was
economy built on industrialization in
the new playbook around Innovation and
encouragement of entrepreneurs they have
to to have credibility and commitment
something the Western Government
struggled with for a long period of time
to learn now is the learning process for
the Chinese government however that said
now you see that in the recent past in
the recent last few months the state has
rolled back some of these heavy blows
invited jackma to come back and there's
a lot of luring private businessmen and
trying to restore that confidence
because guess what today's China's
economy the private sector is firmly in
the driver's seat and they do the heavy
lifting of the economy unlike during the
financial crisis of 2009 they call on
team China State Banks flush with cash
uh and state own Enterprises uh
splurging on infrastructure and you get
the economy back going that no long
longer works so even if the West
believes that there's a statist approach
of President shei and control on S soes
the reality is that pretty much
everything about the economy is driven
by the private sector and the government
ke is keenly aware of that yeah and
obviously now the both the development
of the economy but also this emerging
struggle between the US and China that
we started on technology is absolutely
key to it and how um and there's a
debate some in the in the US say you
know China because it's not as open a
society as us is not going to be able to
advance as rapidly technologically
others say well look at mobile payments
for example where China was way ahead um
and that uh China will in fact um
surprise if you like liberal theorists
and prove that you can have techn rapid
technological advance in a one party
State what what do you think is
happening I mean just on the ground As
You observe these various sort of
groundbreaking Technologies if there is
a race between China and America who's
ahead I think that we ought to be a
little bit more nuanced when we talk
about technology which is a very broad
concept uh China is very strong on
Innovations around business models and
applications and frankly coming up with
practical solutions to real problems by
the way developing countries their
biggest problem is not that they don't
have access to the most Advanced
Technologies but they don't have access
to Technologies they can actually use
and these would be Chinese Technologies
more suitable for them for 80% of the
global population than American
Technology so I believe that because
they're cheaper or simpler to use
because they're cheaper uh cheaper
reliable quality all that access um and
that they solve practical problems so
they're more user friendly uh for
developing countries well give me a
couple of practical examples for
instance uh solar panels or you know the
Renewables is a very good example um EVS
will be a very prominent example
remember that the technology uh
controversial technology Force
technology transfers if you will um
didn't make China leap ahead in
traditional automotives but it's often
in Green Field Technologies where China
has spear ahead e is one one of such
examples but even read in the financial
times no less that next year China will
become the world's largest exporter of
cars China China has became the largest
consumer and producer of EVS within a
decade not least thanks to the
government rolling out 4 million
Chargers around the country as opposed
to 140,000 in the US so talk about and
the State Coordinating uh Supply chains
around these EV companies so that that
comes back to the point about technology
right yes uh the US is printing out a
bunch of you know aggressive policies to
try to hobble China's technological
growth but we have to remember China has
an all-encompassing innovation ecosystem
within the country there's close Pro
proximity between the downstream players
like uh Eves amaas vehicles and um and
artificial intelligence companies with
chip companies their close proximity
means that their demand will drive these
Innovation efforts and we just we have
to remember that there are a lot of UN
expected consequences of American
policies because that just gives a huge
boost to the domestic industry so it's
much more complex than saying us China
technology comp competition and
decoupling mhm and I mean one thing that
everybody's been waiting for is the
moment at which China becomes the
world's largest economy and I think in
purchasing power it happened actually in
2014 but uh but even when that happens
it will still on a per cap per capita
basis be much poorer than the United
States or Western Europe and you write
quite a lot in the book about can they
make this leap from a $110,000 per
person uh economy to a $30,000 per
person economy and that that will be
very difficult I mean are you confident
it'll happen well that's the hard part
the catching up growth I don't want to
uh uh under under underestimate you know
this remarkable economic success story
but catching up is much easier than
becoming a rich country and to become
the $330,000 income per capita a nation
you need Innovation because productivity
growth is the only sustainable source of
economic growth and lots need to change
for instance institutions needs to be
better the financial system which
supports Innovative companies needs to
totally reform they are the last old
dinosaur in the Chinese economy why
because the Chinese State likes control
they don't want to see control they want
to protect retail investors but the
longer they protect the the the the
longer it will take for them to learn
and you can never get a dynamic vibrant
Financial system of course with all the
problems in the US I would still argue
that it's one of the key critical
contributors to CH Us's Innovation uh
system uh and and then of course um as
we were mentioning how do you get a
wider diverse um set of preferences from
businessmen to students to people to be
reflected on the top all of that is
really important um it's easier to copy
Goods but it's very difficult to copy
good
institutions talking of which I mean
the as as I referred to earlier she is
now you know entering his third term and
as some Chinese liberal put it to me
it's not the third term that worries me
it's the fourth it's the fifth do you
think that Chinese institutions have
this flexibility that you think they
need political reforms have lacked
economic reforms I'm not saying that
there there has been none there have
been but it's significantly uh slower uh
and um much less um visible
um I think it is a big challenge I think
the system has always been able to adapt
uh to the uh evolution of society and
the economy even in the last 40 years um
more competition more checks and
balances of course it's taken a few
steps back uh in the recent years and I
do think it's a big challenge but with
today I mean at least for the short term
let's just hope that the fact that she's
Inner Circle are loyalist means that
there's going to be more trust in the
Inner Circle and that there will be more
delegation at least in terms of
practical issues like the economy to The
Experts and to the technocrats and to
trust them yeah and and since there has
just been a reshuffle a lot of these
names won't be familiar to people in the
west but who are the key people in the
Inner Circle who'll be driving things
like economic reform well I would say
that leang the premier um is the most
important figure uh and we have to
remember all these uh standing committee
M members po members have all been deep
profound beneficiaries of Reform and
opening up and they're not going to
forget that that's what changed their
personal lives and Lee's background is
also very interesting because he rose to
the Top by helping private business men
succeed um and he had made famous
speeches even when he was more lowly uh
you know on lowly Municipal levels of if
you guys have great ideas come to me
we're all going to support them uh and
he thoroughly understands the Deep uh
frustrations and challenges that face
private businessmen so he made it he has
made it clear that he wants to support
them and by the way when he was Shanghai
mayor that's when Tesla um also moved
their factories there and he was very
encouraging of these foreign businesses
so I think we have an eminently
practical and sens sensible person in
charge of the economy okay we we've
talked a lot about the things that made
China's growth and this uh economic
miracle I think you can say take place
over the last 40 years uh and you
mentioned things that were crucial
Innovation the private sector and so on
but I guess one thing that was really
crucial was peace that uh this has been
a long you know China hasn't been at War
since
1979 um but now I think certainly in
Washington it's quite striking and
alarming how many people openly talk
about the possibility of a war with
China I haven't been to Beijing since
the since the pandemic but people tell
me the mood is quite nationalistic there
uh um just to finish on a depressing
note but uh how you know somebody again
who knows both societies very well are
you concerned about this Prospect of war
and of sort of mirroring nationalism
because the uh people say that the
rising generation of Chinese you say
they they they're more confident but
that they're some say they're also
pretty nationalistic and that that's
reflected at the top levels of
government and there's a potential for a
clash I think the whole world is
becoming more nationalistic including in
the US in many countries in the round
world and that is deeply worrying you
mentioned something that's absolutely
correct that's deep in the Chinese
people's heart even today and especially
leaders and it is peace uh the the cost
of war is still very fresh in the memory
uh China has not fought a war for
decades as you mentioned so even on this
very timely issue the critical issue of
today of Taiwan we can't forget that
well they haven't had the experience of
these uh military uh uh uh confront
confr ations and so peace is still very
much at the core of the leadership's top
agenda they understand that for China to
reach the aspirations including
president xi's aspirations which is by
the way uh most important making the
Chinese economy the biggest in the world
um requires peace and nobody nobody uh
is going to forget that however um I
think that errors in judgment
miscalculations are increasingly more
likely and sides on both sides and one
cannot tell where the escalation is
coming from it's interactive it's
Dynamic it's endogenous um and the risk
of a miscalculation is is real and I
think both sides understand that but
what we do see is that when the
temperature has been too hot for both um
both sides the presidents have
respectfully tried to cool it down I
think maybe there's a view uh in China
that left to the parties across the
Taiwan straight there's more possibility
of working out a solution a peaceful
solution but the the military conflict
is really the very last resort that
China would want to
see